[Music]  because of the one-shot nature of this  film we had to measure every step of the  journey the scene has to be the exact  length of the land so you have to  rehearse every step of the journey on  location in the early days of free arson  we turnt up to this open fill and we  literally walked through with the script  and we'd mark that out with ticker tape  we had that time how long it would take  the actors to deliver their lines and  make sure that the sets were built to  accommodate the dialogue nothing was  even begun until we knew those basic  things so intense because it was so  precise it was like a piece of theater  every time once it starts it can't stop  or something that those women you just  have to keep going